welcome everyone to this demo on the May
1 and the Jenkins integration here now
in this one we are going to talk about
at how exactly we can indicate both the
J 1 and the Jenkins here just to
implement the CI processes over him now
what is the purpose of Jenkins here now
Jenkins is normally a kind of a CI tool
which we use for performing the build
automations and the test cases
automation there it's one of the open
source tool which is available there and
one of the most popular CI tool also
available into the market now this tool
makes it easier for the developers to
integrate the changes to the project
here so we can easily integrate the
changes and whatever the modifications
we want to manage we will be able to do
that with the help of Jenkins now
Jenkins also achieves the continuous
integration with the help of couple of
plugins each and every tool which you
want to integrate have its own plugins
which is available there for example you
want to integrate maven we have a maven
plug-in in Jenkins which you can install
you can configure in that case you will
be able to use the maven there now you
can now deploy the maven err to build
tool onto the Jenkins server and then
you can prepare or you can configure any
number of them even jobs in case of
Jenkins
so uh what exactly the Maven or the
Jenkins really do is though maven when
integrates with Jenkins through the
particular plugins so you can able to
automate the pills because for
automation the build you require some
integration with the maven and that
integration is what we are getting from
the maven plugin so in Jenkins you have
to install the maven plugin and once the
plug-in is installed so what you can do
is that you can proceed with the
configurations you can proceed with the
setup and this particular plug-in can
help you to build out some of the Java
based projects which is available there
in the control posit risk and once that
is done you will be able to go ahead and
you will be able to process a complete
integration of maven within Jenkins
right so let's see that how we can go
for the integration now I have already
installed the maven onto the Linux
virtual machine which we are using so
using the applet ility or using the yum
utility you can actually download the
Jenkins package and the maven package
onto the server onto the virtual machine
and now I'm going to proceed further
with the plug-in installation and the
configuration of a maven project so I
have a github repository which is having
a maven project maven a source code and
the maven eyes test cases over there so
let's see let's login to the Jenkins and
see that how it works
so this is the Jenkins interface which
we have over here now in this one what
we can do is that we can create some
maven jobs over here and once those jobs
are created we will be able to do a
custom build on two of these Jenkins so
first of all we have to install the
particular plugin here for that we have
to go to the manage Jenkins in manager
Incans you can have the manage plugins
option there so you have to click on
that now here you will be having
different tabs like updates available
installed advanced all these different
tabs are available there so what you can
do is that you can click on the
available one when you go to the
available tab so what will happen that
here you can actually put up that what
exactly plugin you want to fetch here so
I can put a plugin called maven now you
can see that the very first one the
maven integration tool is available so
I'm going to select that particular
plug in and click on download now and
install after restart now once that is
answer what will happen that the plugin
will be downloaded but in order to
reflect the changes we have to do a
couple of restart now you for that you
don't have to go to the virtual machine
you have the option here itself that
will allow you to do the restart over
here when you click on this button so
you check this option and say that
restart Jenkins when the installation is
done so what will happen that the
installation will be automatically
attempted whenever the particular
plug-in installation is completed here
so you just have to refresh the page
again and you will be able to see that
the particulars engines is being
processed as such here right so you can
see that the screen is coming up that
Jenkins is restarting so it will take a
couple of five to six seconds to do the
restart and the login screen to come up
again over there you can do the Refresh
also if you feel automatically it will
be reloaded once the Jenkins is ready
but sometimes we have to refresh it so
that we can get this screen over there
so once the login is done so my maven
integration is done so next thing which
I will be doing is that I will be
creating a maven related project so I'm
going to put the admin user and the
password so whatever the user and
password you have created you are going
to put that so that you will be able to
login to the Jenkins portal now this is
the Jenkins which is of a label here so
all you have to do is that you have to
click on create a new job or new item so
both the option is pretty much same only
so here you will be able to see a maven
project here so I'm going to select like
maven build that's the name which I am
going to give here and the maven project
I'm going to select here and then press
ok
now here you will be providing the first
of all the repository from which you
will be checking out the source code now
I can have a discard old builds over
here so if I feel that I want to have
like a local rotation so all the
previous builds should be deleted so I'm
just saying that dates to keep a build
should be ten over here and the number
of bills which I need to keep over here
is 20 you can adjust these settings
according to your requirement but over
here we are you know doing a kind of
configurations which we are trying to do
a lot of configurations and setting same
so these are the particular settings
which we are looking forward as such
over here so now we are going to have
the log rotation here so we can have it
like how many days we want to keep and
how many number of for billets we want
to keep here so both the values we are
providing go back here and then now I'm
going to put the gate integration here
like the repo URL so I have this
repository here in which I have the Java
source code and some particular junior
test cases and all I also have the
particular source code and it's kind of
a maven project so that's what I am
trying to clone over here with the help
of this plugin so this plugin will
download this repository it will clone
it on to the Jenkins server and then
depending on our integration with maven
the maven build will be triggered here
so now I'm going to process with the
maven here so you can see here that it's
saying that Jenkins needs to know that
where the maven is installed because
that maven version it needs to configure
it needs to process on that part so I'll
just do the same over here and or I can
click on this tool configuration so I'll
just save or do the apply click on this
tool configuration here now here you
have the options like where you can have
the JDK installation but what happens
that same Jenkins is running there so
JDK is automatically installed so in the
tools configuration you don't have to
put the JDK configuration but at least
for the maven configurations you have to
provide that where exactly the maven is
available there so I'm just saying that
maven 3 I want to process and the latest
maven Apache web server I want to
configure here so I just want to have
like I just want to save this setting so
that it will be automatically download
the latest version Apache a three point
six point three version there and that
same should be utilized over here in
this case now I'm just going to the
maven build configuration here and click
on the configure part so these get
repository is available here and in the
build step it automatically builds up
that what maven environment you want to
select so you see that previously since
I did not configured my maven
environment so it was throwing an error
but once I have configured data I have
to download it during the build process
or before the build that utility should
be downloaded so instead of doing the
physical installation of maven on the
server what I have chosen over here is
that I have selected the particular
version like I have selected that
particular point six point three a
version should be installed for the
maven purposes over here
now once that is done I am going to put
the particular
steps over here you can have it like
clean install you can have clean
compiled test clean test or test alone
you can give it just a part of the setup
or the coals which you want to configure
him it by default says that 400 XML file
is the current one in the current
directory you need to refer you need to
pick on that one what it's up to you
only that how you want to configure and
how you want to process as such this
information so according to your
requirement you can say that ok I
haven't just want to go for these
particular goals and you can say like
save over here the particular
quantification will be saved now you can
just click on the bell now and you will
be able to see that the first of all the
git clone will happen and then the
desired maven is repeatable will be the
build tool will be configured and
according to that it will be processed
here so you can see here that the maven
is getting downloaded it's getting the
configured here and once it's configured
because I have explained over there that
three point six point three version I
have to select so that specific version
will be configured and will be picked up
over here now even if you don't have the
maven install on the physical machine on
which the Jenkins is running still you
will be able to do the processing using
this particular component here so you
can see here that we have some
particular test case is executed and in
the end we are able to get a particular
artifacts also there since I did not
call upon the package or install gold
that's a reason why the particular
artifacts was not generated var file or
char file whatever the packaging mode is
available at forum level but still what
happens in my test cases do gets
executed and that's what I have got over
here in this case so this is a kind of a
mechanism where we feel that how we can
configure a git repository once the git
repository is configured you are going
to integrate the maven plug-in in the
maven plugin you are going to configure
in the tools configuration that this and
so-and-so version I want to configure to
run my build and once that is done after
that you just have to trigger the build
and click on the build now option and
once that is done you will be able to
get a particular fulfill a build or
compilation happened on to the champions
and this log will give you the complete
details that what are the different
steps which
has happened on this one so this is how
we really integrate both maven and
Jenkins with each other right so this
was the demo in which we saw that how we
can actually integrate the maven with
Jenkins here so that's it for this one
thanks hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here